Silicon Valley is famously home to tech
giants and billionaires but it's also
home to jovani munguia Brown a childcare
worker at Stanford University name did
you take a nap today together with her
husband and kids she'd been living
happily in East Palo Alto for six years
until an unexpected eviction order
arrived for homelessness to be a reality
for your family I have no choice but to
fight her fight was against Equity
Residential America's largest
publicly-traded landlord founded by
billionaire Sam Zell in late 2011 the
company paid 130 million dollars for her
apartment complex Woodland Park they
twice tried and failed to a victor for
late rent payments then settled after
she could show that required home
repairs had not been completed Equity
Residential would not make anybody
available for an interview with
Bloomberg Television why do you think
the landlord here wants to evict people
like yourself because they can make more
money making they can have more people
move in at market value rate munguia
Brown currently pays around $600 less
than the market value
thanks to rent stabilization laws that
have left East Palo Alto is the last
low-income refuge between San Francisco
and San Jose this bridge marks the
dividing line between the
multimillion-dollar mansions of Palo
Alto and the affordable housing of East
Palo Alto but thanks to the tech boom
here in Silicon Valley that housing may
not remain affordable for much longer
the median sales price for homes in the
upscale neighboring city of Palo Alto
has jumped over the past five years from
around 800,000 to 1.9 million dollars
meaning that young tech workers are
pushed out to places like East Palo Alto
and rents there are pushed up California
law allows a landlord and a rent
stabilized jurisdiction to raise the
rent to market rate for a new tenant
that's a perverse incentive that exists
in the law for Equity Residential it was
a legal incentive to evict in the first
half of 2012
soon after Equity Residential purchased
Woodland Park eviction notices served
against
hence his sword from 14 in a single
month to 311 in one instance the firm
tried to evict a tenant who was just 75
cents short what's unusual is the
aggressive and rapid nature of it most
landlords other than Woodland Park are
not going to take steps to evict a
tenant on the second day of the month
but many tenants here are unaware of
their rights under California and city
law and in this largely Hispanic
community some residents fear
retaliation based on the immigration
status the effect overall is that you're
seeing mass displacement and you're
seeing the entire fabric of this
community changing overnight the last
affordable community in this entire
region the last affordable community in
this region yes councilman Rubin of Rica
has belonged to this community for 30
years
he says rent stabilization was a core
principle on which east palo alto was
founded it's part of our history is part
of who we are we basically made a
commitment our city government will look
after the most vulnerable people in this
community when it comes to housing AB
Rika told me the City Council had
recently passed a new housing ordinance
it's designed to prevent landlords like
the owners of Woodland Park from
threatening behavior delaying repairs or
harassing tenants in this small
community that feels under siege from
the rest of Silicon Valley
you